[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show the
Steve King racism in Congress saga
continues the funniest thing about this
entire Fiasco is that all of a sudden
people are realizing Steve King is
racist when the guy has been saying
horrible stuff since he's been in the
House of Representatives the latest is
that after Steve King's racist remarks
it was announced that he would be kicked
off of his committee assignments and
there are more calls for him to resign a
house Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
announced that he that Steve King is
going to be removed from the house
Republican steering committee or rather
he is not going to be serving in any
committees rather the house steering
committee decided that he's not going to
be serving on any committees there was
also a vote taken about whether his
comments are to be condemned the answer
was yes hilariously Steve King voted in
support of the house condemning his own
comments and wrote them off as not stuff
that he actually sincerely believes and
Mitt Romney senator from Utah a former
governor of Massachusetts has said that
there's no place for Steve King in the
House of Representatives and then he
should resign you know Pat that when
even other Republicans like Mitt Romney
are saying that the guy should go it's
very low-hanging fruit and they would
only do that if it was obvious that
there was no political repercussion to
being a Republican and calling for
another Republican to resign and it is
time for King to go yeah and of course
Steve King's latest comment and there
have been many this time he said white
nationalist white supremacist Western
civilization how did that language
become offensive so that means that he's
outraged that white supremacists as the
term has become offensive okay so I
think if any other Republican had said
this you may be able to justify the case
that they're not racist and they just
had a slip of the tongue a lapse in
judgment and you still condemn the
comments but you wouldn't necessarily
conclude that they're racist Steve King
on the other hand is a long tracker dove
track record of this he's talked about
illegal immigrant
coming across the border smuggling drugs
with cantaloupe calves this is just the
latest in a long string and I think he
should be removed from those committee
assignments at the very least maybe even
ousted from Congress you know what's the
most depressing element of this entire
story our friend JD Schulten rang ran
against Steve King in the 2018 midterms
and he lost but narrowly and JD Shelton
was a great candidate I got a chance to
meet him hang out a little an interview
him at Netroots nation in New Orleans in
August of 2018 and not only was JD
Shelton a great candidate he was running
against someone who is one of the worst
in the Republican Party in the House of
Representatives and by not that many
votes JD Scholten lost and Steve King
was reelected he may now end up having
to step aside we'll see if the pressure
gets too big we could have not even had
to deal with this path if JD Scholten
had gotten a few more votes and had
Elstad Steve King we would all be so
much better off if that had been the
case but I wonder if the vote was held
today after these comments surfaced
would JD Shelton have had a chance at
winning like maybe Steve King would have
still been able to pull it off because
this kind of language has already baked
into the cake people know who this guy
is and I don't know if Iowa voters would
be all that offended by this I don't
know I mean remember the situation in
Alabama where Doug Jones defeated Roy
Moore who was under the cloud of
multiple sexual sexual assault
allegations including of underage girls
and he only barely lost to Doug Jones I
kind of have a feeling that if you've
been supporting Steve King for a while
you probably wouldn't be swayed to vote
for a Democrat because of some offhanded
comments about white nationalism
yeah that's an unfortunate reality but
this is the country that we live in
let's talk about Russia and Ukraine
Russia's top security official has
warned that neighboring Ukraine may no
longer be a country soon as the former
Soviet republic is divided by competing
interests the unrest in Ukraine has gone
back a really long time I guess we could
say
current incident or current set of
conflicts go back to roughly 2014 when
an uprising a ousted the former
ukrainian President Viktor Yanukovych
and now we are actually hearing from
Russian Security Council secretary
Nikolai patrushev who warned yesterday
that the current strategy of the
Ukrainian president could lead to a
total end of the country of Ukraine and
of course all of the language they use
pat is always couched to have some kind
of double meaning where you can't just
straight up say these are direct threats
and we need to if we care about a joint
defense agreement with Ukraine we need
to activate around them they're always
slick enough and clever enough and smart
enough to couch it in a way where maybe
it's not a threat and it's simply an
observation that this could lead to the
self-destruction of Ukraine rather than
anyone coming in and doing anything but
in the background there's always these
thinly veiled threats of aggression I
think you still though have to take the
comments seriously especially in the
wake of their annexation of Crimea in
2013 2014 and the big concern is that
Ukraine is not a part of NATO so how
would the international community
respond to such a thing if they were to
take over the entire country of Ukraine
like if Russia had taken something else
in the Soviet bloc like Estonia Latvia
Lithuania because I think those are all
three NATO countries we would have an
obligation to go to war with Russia the
same pick the same can't be said about
Ukraine and especially when you have a
guy like Donald Trump in office how
would the u.s. handle such a thing yeah
I mean I might stop short of saying we
hoped we would have an obligation to go
to war with Russia but we would be
committed to participating in the joint
defense of Ukraine if they were a NATO
member that kind of makes this more
interesting which is that as Pat
mentions Ukraine is not a NATO member so
ultimately that doesn't mean that NATO
countries wouldn't participate in
helping Ukraine but it would mean that
there's not this automatic defense that
they've committed to it would be a
discussion and they would have to make
the decision as to
what do we want to do about the Ukraine
situation and presumably they would want
to be acting together of course the wild
card there is Donald Trump and his
relationship with Vladimir Putin and how
that would impact the u.s. decision but
in the midst of all this you have a
number of sources now saying that Donald
Trump is still actively considering
leaving NATO which again it's a story in
and of itself but it's part of this
policy that we've seen of being
deferential to Russia in a way that kind
of beat goes beyond logic and what we
would expect to see an American
president doing and all these stories
are related I mean still I don't know if
I've missed it Pat but I've still not
seen any serious response by Trump or
the United States to Russian aggression
Russian Navy aggression against
Ukrainian Navy aggression which we
covered a few weeks ago ramming a ship
and taking a couple of sailors I've
still not seen Trump say a word about it
no in Trump's entire administration
pretty much every policy position that
he's taken pretty much every action that
he's taken has been favorable to Russia
the only exception would be that time
that he bombed that Syrian Air Base
where Russian planes were flying but
even then they got warning about that
and you know I hate to do this but you
have to start thinking about comparisons
to world war two in Nazi Germany
Hitler's slowly but surely took over
land that was german-speaking land that
was historically German like state and
land Austria could you make that
comparison to what Russia is doing with
with Ukraine taking Crimea and then
threatening their ships and maybe
wanting to take over the entire country
eventually I don't know that I would be
ready to make that comparison right now
and I think a key difference there aside
from just the language is that remember
NATO was signed after World War two so a
key difference if we think about okay
let's assume Putin gets away with
everything in Ukraine and then he wants
to go further pretty quickly he would
start to butt up against NATO members
and even if Trump pulled the u.s. out of
NATO I mean listen who anything can
always happen but I just don't see that
it would be allowed to really go any
further although I could be I could be
depressingly wrong I real
hope that you're right I just worry that
if there was ever a time for Putin to
act - it would be now that he has the
guy like Trump in the Oval Office in the
United States yeah I there's no question
about that if there were a time to pull
antics like that it probably would be
right now we talked a couple weeks ago
or the week before last week I guess I
would call it the week before this one
also known as last week about
congresswoman Alexandria Castillo Cortez
floating the idea of a top marginal tax
bracket of 70% we broke down how
marginal tax brackets work how it could
hypothetically work on income above 10
million 50 million whatever you could
set it wherever it is you think makes
sense there's now a new poll the hill
Harris X Survey poll conducted between
January 12 and 13
after Alexandria Castillo for Ted Kord
has made the call for that pot or
suggested floated a 70 percent top
marginal tax rate 59 percent of
registered voters support the idea of a
70 percent top marginal tax rate women
supported by a slightly larger margin
than men women supported 62 to 38 men
supported 55 to 45 and it is popular in
all regions of the country
southerners back at 57 to 43 rural
voters back at 56 to 44 so there are a
lot of people in general but
particularly right wing are surprised by
this level of support and you really you
know the truth is Pat if you understand
how marginal tax brackets work it makes
sense that this would have pretty
significant support because we're
talking about number one a marginal tax
break not take a bracket not taking 70%
of anyone's total income but taxing
income above a certain certain threshold
at 70% so that this is going to affect a
very small percentage of the population
and it also is only going to affect part
of their income so this is another one
of those examples of when you ask people
do you believe the government has a
basic duty
provide some healthcare to everybody
even if they can't afford it most people
say yes you've separated from the
politics similarly this is another
example of how Americans as voters would
support far more progressive policies
than that which our elected officials
support I still though am quite
surprised with the polling data I would
have thought that Republicans have over
time won the argument when it comes to
just you know presenting the idea that
this is you know their money and you
shouldn't have a right to it in that
rich people are job creators it makes no
sense for us to take more from them than
we do from average citizens and that you
know you as a commoner may one day
become rich and be susceptible to having
to pay these seventy percent tax rate
having to pay the estate tax I always
thought that they kind of won out on
that but this polling data suggests
otherwise well I think the both can be
true which is that were it not for that
narrative these numbers would be even
more overwhelmingly in favor of the 70
percent marginal tax rate in other words
instead of fifty nine percent of all
Americans saying yes tax the top incomes
at 70 percent marginal you might have 69
percent or 79 percent or something like
that so I do think that it's been a
successful narrative in many circles
that's why it's only 59% when many
people would look at this from other
countries and say of course we should be
doing that why not yeah and remember the
Trump supporters they talk about making
America great again it's often hard to
pinpoint when they think America was so
great but when you do get an answer it's
usually around the 1950s 1960s and
remember under Eisenhower in the 1950s
the top marginal tax rate was something
like 91% now no one was actually paying
that much because of like the loopholes
and of course these are just marginal
tax rates they're not effective but if
you think that was such a great time
maybe we should go back to that maybe
you should be happy that Alexandria
Castile Cortes is only suggesting 70%
and not 91% I agree with you now they
already have a talking point they say
that everything was completely different
during the times of high marginal tax
rates and high growth that the situation
then in the United States was not
analogous to the situation now
whether we agree with that or not would
require further exploration while I
agree with you Pat they already have a
talking point in place to refute that
one yeah send me your thoughts about
where do you think 70% should start
should it be
above five hundred and ten thousand
dollars which is currently the top tax
bracket should it be on incomes above a
million ten million 20 million where
would you like to see 70% to come the
marginal tax bracket will follow up if
you get good data from our bonus show
audio the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]